the gyro can experience Oh gentlemen I
was in the New York during the you know
the hurricane sandy and we were talking
about before the show but like you got a
doomsday prep I mean like unfortunately
I prepped for the wrong doomsday right
which one did you prep for I don't know
invasion of clowns for a good one
a good one but annoying like clowns
would be everywhere and we have to fight
him off with like water guns and stuff
like that rappers yeah exactly
this was like just fuckin it was like
apocalyptic it really was
that's hilarious I mean um no much did
you expect it to be like that it was it
way crazier than expected you know the
thing about New York though is since
9/11 like our first responders are like
top-notch they really like step up they
know what they do they've got plans and
all that kind of stuff but nobody I
guess expected like New York City
tsunami like wave hitting us knocking
out power for like two weeks and then
there's like Staten Island Jersey where
they've got it even harder but you take
the power out of New York City and you
got Somalia
basically it's just a freaky weird scary
town you know yeah it's really strange
when you see how easy the the film that
covers civilization can be removed and
people savage it just becomes a survival
real so you really have to worry about
survival because the first responders
are excellent don't get me wrong
right they're overwhelmed there's just
yes your numbers impossible to deal with
there was parts of the city where like I
was just walking around and it was just
dark and like guys would roll up on you
like you can't see him and I'm pretty
good like Nick know what's happening I
got to roll up on me and I'm like wow
this is like a Chuck Norris you know
that scene in every Chuck Norris movie
was like in the factory right was like a
box knocks over yeah it was like that
kind of thing like just weird scary
faces and just sounds what is it like to
walk around a street at night with no
gun on it's a no gun no I was like fuck
what am I gonna fight him with sarcasm
what's going on here so we're walking
like to where you how to go to and fro
in your neighborhood there was no lights
on for days no lights
it I where I lived there was lights but
when you like we did shows at the Comedy
Cellar which is in the village they had
no lights up until almost the last day
and we were doing chose two generators
which is kind of
pulling away but bad because it went out
when I was on but it went out and all
these flashlights and candles started
popping out of the crowd it was like
that scene in requiem for a dream you
know it seemed like weather like ask to
ask the flashlight stuff so it was
really it was really a freaky show but
it was a good show but when you're
walking around the streets you're like
okay this is like you know what do i
what can I fight whoever comes at me
with with the weapon and there's a lot
of like homeless people coming off of
their meds too so there's like they have
like the extra evil in them you know oh
that's right because they can't get
their meds because there's no power it
was like zombie style zombie I was what
a walking dead kind of shit yeah that's
scariest fuck now the Whizzer a lot of
that like it was are a lot of muggings
was there a lot of it was there was some
looting there was some whatever but it
wasn't like Katrina cuz I talked to guys
who were in Katrina now like you know
everybody's like this is art Katrina
it's like fuck no this is like Katrina
was like the end of the earth that was
the end of the world there that was like
weeks and weeks and weeks no help you
know yeah and no power and it was hot
not stuff in New York it was a little
bit better than that that's for sure so
it's better than that but it's still it
was bad it lets you know what can go
wrong in the biggest city in the world
yeah exactly when that happens when the
biggest city in the world gets
essentially shut down for two weeks
that's a real eye-opener oh absolutely
you know like people trying to get into
the city and they had to do you know
like buses and all the trains were like
exactly like somebody shoulda kayak
through these tunnels just to do it like
to say like I did it I didn't even think
about what it must be like at night with
no power I didn't even think about my
pain inside
yeah not have left well you kind of it's
kind of like how do you see were you
going it's scary so unless it's a full
moon how do you see where you've got
exactly you know the scariest thing I
saw was when I was like driving around
like I was in a cab and a cab by the way
we're like incredibly hard to get at
that point but there was like a candle
in a window of a project and I'm like
this is what its gonna look like after a
nuclear winter like just like one
holdout guy in a project somewhere like
you know like Charlton Heston in right
you know in that Omega Man kind of thing
and you know I was like this is it this
is what it looks like you know I
I was a freak it freaks a lot of people
out but then I think the gas thing
freaked them out even more the fact they
couldn't get gas for their generators
and cars and said they're online for
like 12 15 hours yeah I talked to a
friend who said he was online it was
2:30 in the afternoon he had been there
too since 6:00 in the morning you still
yeah easily easily yeah that's crazy we
never we never I don't think even the
government local whatever state thought
like there's gonna be a gas problem you
know and nobody was ready so wow you
need that gas for the generators too so
Jesus crisis yeah am i bringing everyone
down but it was getting material for a
minute all oh yeah I got tons I mean
like you know the whole idea of like you
know basically doing shows like in New
York like the top of the line like guys
who pull the most pone or like you know
the hedge fund guys you know the club DJ
you know the male model who's you know
bi or whatever but that week it was all
like Renaissance Fairs skills like
candle maker blacksmith you know any guy
who could hook a bike up to a light you
know he would get like you know
definitely at least the reach-around you
know that's that Yukon man show you ever
seen yeah those are important they have
generators that work on water flow oh
they take a generator they set it up at
their camp they have a fish camp and
they put this generator they set it up
and then they attach these tubes to it
and they stick the tubes in the creek
and the water coming down the creek goes
through the tubes and by the time it you
know it focuses in this one area it
spins this thing around and starts to
generate I want that it's fuckin crazy I
watched he pulls the cord and burn it's
going on it's not electricity a hundred
percent from the creek spinning this
generator so as long as this generator
keeps working
he had his lights on the whole it's
crazy and that really is the one thing
that you need is like power you know it
really is the one thing that separates
us from animals
well we've somehow or another just
accepted that that's gonna be around
even though it's only been here for a
hundred and fifty years or whatever the
hell it's been we were so used to it you
know a million years of human beings in
a 150 years of power we're just like
that's how we do it we got power I could
see myself going to my ex-girlfriends
house and just hanging out and because
she would have like all the candles in
the world yeah girls yeah and all doop
/ handles a girl has is directly
proportionate to exactly how long she
will cry ft of sex work but yeah girls
were prepped a little bit harder than
dude handles Mentos you know there's
like 30 candles that bitch is gonna cry
mom is petroleum based you know whatever
girl shit but I have a lot of different
things to help you in survival situation
exactly and I'll tell you you know who
really did not step up for this crisis
the dogs of New York City it's like
every other person in New York has a dog
when it's all these faggoty has little
dogs right and I was like they've been
genetically built all the cool like wolf
qualities that would have helped we're
gone so they're like what are we gonna
do any food yeah there when the snow hit
afterwards no I was already out of there
but that was like a one-two punch of
like said fuck man a blizzard and the
really scary thing is that they're
saying who's the Governor Cuomo Andrew
Cole yes
yeah he's he seems a good guy he said
something really interesting he said I
don't want to use the term climate
change I'm paraphrasing him because it's
such a loaded topic he said but you know
his father had to deal with in 12 years
he had to deal with two major storm
events right and he's like I've been
here for 12 months and I've had a deal
with three Wow you know so he's saying
like there's it's very possible
something's going on I think there's
definitely something going on
no that's never happened in New York
before well you know a buddy of mine I I
assume you know him too big Jay oakerson
yes he's a great know of them do you
know of him okay yep you probably
haven't work with him yet but really
funny guys tour with me a couple times
his house was wiped out he was like in
the flood flood zone zone a whatever he
said you know it really is weird like
when a flood comes at your house I'm
lucky I like lived up you know up in
that skyscrapers but the scary part
about that is like if the power goes out
then you're like trying to kind of stuck
up there and so like you know you know
whatever happens so you're stuck up to
until the water drains out exactly you
know that's scary shit skeleton you know
basically yeah no Warren I believe in
the theory that it was a terrorist
attack
exactly but I think all the terrors are
now hot weather ladies with beards
Neptune Laden well your first part made
sense the second part
just like your Hitler cat with the
fucking dynamite strapped to his chest I
don't know what you try to happen and a
lot of people were just basically
milling around a lot of like fires you
know on the street like people making
fires and grind out on the street right
which I think they should allow them to
do hell yeah why not you keep a sense of
social exact negativeness
and yeah it was bad with their food
shortages a supermarket question yes
like the first night like everybody
prepped in terms of like you better buy
milk and bread they would say that no
can braid all the you know what we call
french toast that we make and then like
the next day you know you're like okay
there'll be more nothing there was
nothing left all the people from
downtown who didn't have access to food
came uptown like a horde and like no no
what we call it it was good that they
did it cuz they had no food and they
kind of swept through all the bodegas
and stuff like that so it was like wiped
out wow that must have been strange yeah
I mean like II always assume in America
there's gonna be food you know the other
thing is the cell phone towers were
downtown so even if you had a cell phone
you couldn't call anybody
my friend Tommy said he'd draw he drove
six hours to make a cell phone call he
had I just drive around until he could
find service but it was six hours before
yeah that's crazy
no Coco had service though did you see
the video she was posting of her like in
the rain with quick o iced teas wife how
dare you she's a special bling yeah shit
cell phone servers inches is posting
these awesome videos of her in the
hurricane like rain hitting her while
she's wearing like no clothes she's like
oh it's so pretty